hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve a problem
daily temperatures we are just given an
array of
integers which represent temperatures
and we want to return an array
answer such that at every single
position in answer it's going to be the
same exact size as
our temperatures array and at every
single position in answer we want to
know
for the eighth day whatever the
temperature was on the i
day we want to find how many days did it
take for us
to find a temperature that was greater
than the temperature on the eighth day
so for example let's take a look at this
uh
temperatures array we can see there's
eight values in the temperatures array
and there's eight values in the output
for
each value in the temperatures array for
example 73
how many days did it take us in this
array to
to the right of of 73 how many days did
it take us to find a new
temperature that was greater than 73
well on the
on the exact next day we found 74 which
is greater than 73
so it took us one day so in the first
position we're going to return a 1.
what about 74 how many days did it take
us to find a new temperature that was
greater than it
75 one day later right okay for 75
how many days did it take us 71 is not
greater
69 is not greater 72 is not greater but
is greater and you can see that took
about four
days right so then we return a four in
that position now there are some
temperatures
that never had a temperature greater
than them look at these
last two temperatures we had a 76
nothing to the right of 76 is greater
than it and of course the last position
there's no temperatures to the right of
it in the first place so nothing
was greater than 73 to the right so for
these ones we're gonna return a default
value of zero
so we're gonna build an output array now
looking at the
the input what's the brute force way to
do it of course we could do an
n squared approach right like for every
temperature we would look through the
entire temperature array
after it right and see okay how many
days did it take us to find a
temperature that was greater than this
one right and then
do the same thing for the next
temperature over here look through the
entire or i see
you know what's the first day that we
could find a greater temperature and
keep doing that now that's going to be
big o
of n squared time complexity but there
actually is an
easier way to do this problem if we use
some extra memory
now let's just iterate through the input
array once
going to the right but we do need to
know that for example
we have to remember the previous
temperatures
that we looked at so if we you know
let's say the previous temperature here
was a 73 like in the input example and
then the next temperature
was a 74 when we get to this position we
have to somehow remember
what was the temperature that came
before it right now obviously we could
use a list for that or in this case a
stack would be more intuitive
because one thing we're going to notice
is if we get a temperature
greater than at 74 right then we're
going to say okay what was our previous
temperature 73 so this temperature is
greater than it right
so we can we can keep track of what
index this
occurred at and what index we're at
right now and say okay the difference
between these indexes
was one right we clearly found a
temperature the first temperature
greater than the 73 so then what are we
going to do from our stack well then we
don't have to remember this anymore
right we're going to say okay we're
going to put a 1 in the output and we
can pop this
from our stack right so we're going to
do stack.pop
so this will be popped from the stack
now when we get to a 75 the exact same
thing is going to happen right clearly
we see these temperatures are in
increasing order so we see okay one day
it took us
to get r to get a temperature greater
than this we'll put a one in the output
pop this from the stack and
if we just had increasing temperatures
that would be really easy for us right
but it's not always going to happen
where we have increasing temperatures
what happens
if we had a 72 that came after it
well we would we would look at the 72
and compare it to the top of the stack
say okay this is not
greater so we can't pop from the stack
but we're also going to take this value
and add it to the sec so now we're going
to have two values
inside of our stack and what happens if
we got another
smaller value 71 right so far for none
of these values
do they have a temperature to the right
of them that's greater right
so all three of these are going to be on
the stack what are we noticing about our
stack
it's going to be in monotonic
decreasing order right
this is a type of stack problem that i
have solved on this channel a couple
times but this is more of a beginner
friendly monotonic
decreasing stack problem what this means
is that our stack is going to be in
decreasing order that's what monotonic
means it's always in decreasing order
now technically
what if what happens if we got another
71 over here right
well in that case 71 is not greater than
this so
all four of these would be on our stack
currently right so it's technically not
monotonic
decreasing order it could be equal as
well right we're noticing it's not
strictly decreasing if two values are
equal they're also going to go on the
stack
but if we got a greater value if i got
to a 72 right
what am i gonna do clearly 72 is greater
than the top of our stack so i pop
this one right but now we have a new
value on the top of our stack
this one is is our 72 greater than this
it's not
so so our stack is like this now we
looked on our stack we took
this guy out this is no longer in our
stack but these three values are in our
stack and still
notice how the the stack is still in
monotonic decreasing order it's always
going to be the case
what happens if instead of a 72 i had a
73 then of course we'd still pop this 71
and then we'd we'd also want to pop the
72 because now 73
is greater than 72 we pop this but it's
not the case
for this one but if you know we change
this value to a 74
excuse my bad handwriting over here but
if we change this to a 74
then yes we are going to pop this one as
well so no matter what we do
our stack is always going to be in
monotonic decreasing order if i
add a 70 over here it's we're not going
to pop anything
it's still in decreasing order so let's
just run through a quick simulation let
me show you how we can get this output
in linear time
using a stack so first value 73
we're going to compare it to the top of
our stack our stack is empty so we're
not going to do anything we're just
going to take the 73 add it to the stack
next we're at 74 we're going to compare
it to the top of the stack
74 is greater than 73 right what index
did 73
occur at at index 0 what index does 74
occur
at index one so we take the difference
one minus zero so
it took us one position to find a value
greater than
73 so we can pop 73 from our stack and
then 74
is going to be on the top of our stack
now now exact same thing is going to
happen with 75 right
75 is greater than this the difference
between the indexes
is one so we add a one to the output 474
and we pop 74 now we're at and we add 75
to the stack
next we get 71. 71 is not greater than
the top of our stack so all we do is add
it
we don't update the output in either of
those positions
again we get a smaller value 69 so we
add it to the stack we can't pop any of
these 69's not
greater than either of these next we get
a 72 right
72 is greater than 69 right so we pop 69
what was the difference between the
indices it was one so we're going to
take
in the corresponding output position
which is in this position for 69 we're
going to say okay there was an
index difference of 1. now we're going
to look at the next top for our stack
71.
so the difference between these two is
two so for 71 we're going to say it took
two days for us to find a greater
temperature than 71 so
for this position we add a 2 so we pop
71 from our stack
now 72 is not greater than 75 so we
still have a hole in our output over
here we never found a greater
temperature than 75 yet
and similarly for 72 we have a hole
next we get 76 and compare it to the top
of our stack
so 76 is greater than 72 we pop 72 the
difference
the number of days it took us was just
one day so we can add a one
for 72 and then we look at the next top
of our stack
yes we finally found a temperature
greater than 75
it took us one two three four days to do
that so we can add a
four in the output in the corresponding
position over
here and we can pop 75 from our stack i
think i just need one more
square over here because we have one
last temperature in our input 73 so
we're going to add 73
see 73 is not greater than 76 so we
can't pop that
and now at the end we have no more
temperatures to add right we still have
two temperatures
left in our stack and whatever the
default value
for the unpopped uh temperatures is just
gonna be zero right they told us
in the uh description of the problem
that if we can't
get a greater temperature we're just
gonna put zero for these
so that's how we build the output you
can see it exactly matches
the output that they built in the
example and
we did that in linear time by using this
monotonically
decreasing stack in o of end time of and
memory
so now let's jump into the code so we
are going to have a result or answer
array and it's initially going to be
default values of 0 because that's kind
of what they tell us
and it's going to be the exact same
length as the input array temperatures
i'm also gonna have a stack remember
this is our extra memory it's gonna
uh contain a pair of values in the in
the drawing example
i only showed that we're adding the
temperature but we're also gonna add the
index of the temperature so we can
calculate the difference basically
calculate the number of days it took us
to find a greater temperature so we're
going to be adding two values
to the stack a pair of temperature and
the index that that temperature occurred
at
next we're just going to iterate through
the uh temperatures array we're going to
enumerate this meaning we're going to
get the in
the index of it and the value at the
same time it just makes the code a
little bit cleaner
i is the index t is the temperature
first thing we're going to do is
see does is our stack empty and if it is
is this temperature greater than the
temperature on the top of our stack
the top of our stack is index negative
one in python
and the temperature is the first value
in that pair so index
zero and so if this is true of course we
can pop from our stack right so
stack.pop
so i'm going to call it the stack
temperature and the stack
index which we just popped right and for
this
temperature we want to you know in the
result output say okay
whatever the index of this temperature
was stack index we want to compute the
number of days it took us to find a
greater temperature we can do that with
i the current temperature that we're at
minus
the temp the index of the
uh temperature that we just popped and
we take the difference of those that
gives us the number of days it took to
find a greater temperature and then
we're just adding it to the stack at the
corresponding position we want to
and then once that while loop is done it
might execute zero times it might
execute multiple times
after it's done then we finally want to
append to the stack
the temperature that we're currently
traversing so a pair the
t the temperature value and the index of
that temperature
and once we're done with that we can go
ahead and return our result the reason
we don't have to fill
in any extra zeros if our stack is
non-empty is because we already
initialized
our result to b0 so if we never filled
anything in
the default value is automatically gonna
be zero
so you can see the solution works and is
pretty efficient so i hope this was
helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching